and he's looking very calm duda opens
with the english opening and uh we've
seen this before plenty of times
actually this tournament a real trend
but not this move bringing the white
knight out early attacking black's pawn
in the center this is traditionally not
supposed to be so good because black can
even push a pawn forward and attack this
knight uh white has to lose a lot of
time hopping around the board with his
knight and that happens dude a provoking
prague and we're seeing something very
sharp early on and a trade of nights
simon what do you think of this opening
um this is very unique opening actually
i've never actually seen the white
knight coming out so early for for white
so clearly dude
and his second have been preparing us
but uh prague doesn't seem bothered does
he you know he just he just plays very
quickly uh straight into um dude's
preparation uh it's probably going to
come down to that black pawn in the
middle of the board is that black pawn
on the middle board strong or weak
because you can see
black's defending it white's attacking
it so we'll have to wait and see but at
the moment you know uh prague has a
space advantage as well which is useful
yeah
i was just going to say this actually
seems to be a speciality of uh i think
he's from russia just judging by his
name rachmaninoff no man off
and i can see that he's had mixed
results and arriving late magnus carlton
now to face eric hansen the arbiter is
up on the podium helping
eric fix
something hopefully they are good to go
now magnus carlsen he definitely needs
to win this match
to have any hopes of winning the
tournament and he is a big favorite
against eric hanson the game should
start
very soon you didn't get up to mischief
simon
sorry you didn't get up to mischief
there on their board oh no no no no as
much as i've been tempted to you know
just play the odd move on some of the
balls before they turn up so they
pre-move one f3 it's probably not the
time place to do that isn't it
i mean
no
not at the business end of a tournament
and
okay dude has just brought out the white
queen attacking a pawn in front of it on
this b file but that can be easily
defended by moving that pawn and that's
how prague reacts the white queen it's
not exactly clear what she's doing out
there i'm sure she'll retreat at some
point
immediately retreats
so losing a move for white but just
having loosened up black's pawn
structure the black pawn structure now
slightly uh weaker than it previously
was and prague continues by developing
his queen is he hinting that the black
king is going to go and castle on this
side of the board on the left side if it
does then prague is really in a fighting
mood
and uh actually this type of position
it's more usual with uh colors reversed
i've seen this many many times and
normally that's what happens both kings
castle on the queen side on the left
side
uh often they both become targets a bit
later on
remember as well if prague wins this
match if magnus doesn't win his match uh
in normal time in the rapids then prague
is already the champion with one day to
spare
so i kind of feel like today is a
critical day for prague because if he
wins this match i think he's going to
win win the competition i know he's got
to play a niche tomorrow but he's very
capable of that and i i feel like
duder's style um is very tricky style um
and you can see he's already gone for
quite a tricky line that this is this is
going to be a real challenge you know
and and deuteros you know he's one of
the strongest people
in this competition he's world cup
winner um so i think this is a big big
big match
the setup that white's gone for of his
last move he's getting ready to
move that dark square bishop i mean we
can maybe point just where that bishop
can go to and um this is something that
duder actually goes for a lot of time
doesn't he plays this kind of thing and
then he starts advancing his pawns on
the other side of the board often
and i expect that's quite a normal plan
here to at least get some space
somewhere uh but it's yeah i i've never
i've played the english most of my life
but i've never seen this kind of
position so it's uh it's certainly quite
fresh yeah we should mention it has a
really bad reputation this type of
position for white for example in this
position if prague just castles queen
side it does look a bit loose uh
especially on these light squares that's
why prague is hesitating right now but
if he gets one more move and kind of
tucks his king into the corner and just
covers it up nice and safe then prague
should be doing quite well white can
develop the bishop of simon mentions to
this long diagonal but it's a bit
blocked for now and uh usually prague is
the one as well who can start maybe by
tucking his king in the corner and wants
white's king castles you've got to be
careful of this because the black knight
might jump in but usually one plan for
black just gaining space on this side of
the board you have this really strong
point in the middle which for now does
look stronger it doesn't look too much
of a weakness and by pushing this h pawn
up the board it's actually very hard for
white to find a plan
for example you could see a situation
like this where white is completely
stuck can't really push this for pawn
forward without being captured can't
push this pawn forward without being
captured and it's very much black who
can slowly improve
you need to find a good home for this
bishop of course maybe the black rook
will actually develop itself this way
later to look at some pawns um so this
is what i'm expecting to happen but
pride first plucking up the courage i
think he should castle this way even if
it does look a bit
shaky yeah and uh interestingly enough
the plan that you highlighted is
actually a plan where the expert
alexander rachmanoff actually lost in
that type of way so i'm kind of curious
what does duda have up his sleeve you
know why is he playing something which
doesn't have a great reputation
maybe he's he he was hoping that prague
wouldn't understand his position
wouldn't be prepped in this position but
i think just the speed that prague's
playing it is clear that he he's
analyzed basically everything everything
any opening out there prague prague's
done it that's what he's done in his
couple of years off he's just analyzed
all the chess ball openings that are
possible and anything else as well
because if someone played this against
me night of three i'd be like
i've played chess you know for 35 years
and i've never seen this move and i'd be
thinking but young 16 year old prague
straight away knows what to do which is
quite incredible actually because uh you
know how can he expect this how can he
expect this opening
yeah youngsters these days though they
play thousands and thousands of games
online so maybe the chances are that
he's had this position at least or this
opening uh at least once or twice out of
those thousands and thousands of games
and also as i mentioned simon so this
the it started as the english opening
but it's basically the sicilian defense
but with colors reversed and with colors
reversed it's uh it's not popular of
course but there have been many kind of
opening articles on it some videos
released on this opening that white is
employed just with the other uh with the
other color so maybe prague recognizes
this opening when he has white and he's
just trying to kind of get used to the
visual kind of confusion of having the
black pieces in this pawn structure that
he normally has uh with white so he's
moving pretty quick isn't he still i
mean yeah it was interesting what you
were saying there about the amount of
games you play online and this was
something that happened in poker
and why poker play became so much
stronger that you know before they had
internet poker you'd have to go and play
live a live poker thing maybe you could
play i don't know let's say 100 hands in
two hours but nowadays you can play like
you know ten thousand hands in two hours
and the amount of information you get
and you can learn from is so much
quicker and that's what happened in
poker everyone was learning at such an
accelerated rate because they were just
getting much more information and i
think the same thing is obviously
happening chess there's so much
information there's so you can play so
many games online now that that's
another reason uh the improvement of
youngsters is so rapid it was
interesting that you say that because i
was having a discussion with a
grandmaster friend and he was saying to
me you know chess is getting harder
these days because all those traps that
we used to set for our opponents
they've probably fallen for them online
they played so many games
that's right yeah and it's very hard now
to uh
you used to be able to when i started
playing get a good opening in most games
and you could use that same idea for
years you know i played the same idea
even when i was an international master
and i just do it for two years non-stop
now you play it once you won't better
play it again because someone would have
looked at that and found a good response
so it's uh so it's a different it's a
different game now really in some
respects the only exception to the rule
is hikaru nakamura he's been studying
some traps that uh has
actually many grand masters have fallen
into and consistently as well
um meanwhile there have been some
developments but they've kind of
fallen along the same line that david
kind of highlighted
black sorry whites has been prevented
from expanding on the right side and uh
here we get to see duda's big idea he's
going to remaneuver the night
to
a post i'm presuming that it's going to
head towards the center yeah that white
knight retreating but it is quite
flexible it can jump forward in two
different directions uh later on and
prague just deciding how to deal with
that meanwhile
also the position of the kings we should
talk about they have both positioned
themselves on the queen side and note
how after castling long as we call it
they did take a time out to move again
towards the corner of the board and
basically it's a mirror image we're used
to players i think 90 of games they
castle on the short side on what we call
the king side on the other flank and
there the king is already right next to
the corner uh it's nearly always a good
idea if you do castle on the opposite
flank on the long side to just take a
timeout put your king
where these guys have placed their king
right now
just super safe
i would slightly prefer the position of
black's king at the moment although it
looks a bit loose just because there are
no white pieces around it whereas the
white king if you look at it there's
actually a black bishop on the same
diagonal
so if the position does open up black's
light square bishop pointing down at the
white queen and the white
king oh both of them yeah that's
something that uh judo have to be
careful of later on there might be
tricks to open up that diagonal later on
so white's king not entirely safe maybe
we'll see it shuffle even further into
the corner later in the game i'm very
surprised that
this opening has been recommended and
played by duda to be honest because it
doesn't look very nice to me i mean i
don't know horrible
you got the white pieces you should be
pushing for an advantage and you go into
a cramped position and you start you
start doing these weird night maneuvers
and it's really hard to maneuver nights
when you're when you're cramped i mean
because you don't have much space to
maneuver man i'm not even sure what that
night's going i mean uh uh is it got a i
don't know i don't really know i don't
know what the plan is and
i don't i don't understand this this
opening ploy at all
all will be revealed because uh dudeo
seems to be playing as though you know
this is all his preparation
this is what he had earlier
uh how did they say that that expression
earlier at home or something yeah quite
super fast what i made spending a lot of
time on this
uh previous move yeah spending a lot of
time prague maybe because he's just as
shocked as we are here in the studio
about what duda is doing i really do
like prague's move in general uh pushing
that pawn stopping the white knight kind
of leaping forward to the center taking
one square away from this white knight
but it is quite committal he's blocked
up the pawn structure completely
so kind of pros and cons there but yeah
most of all it's the clock situation
duda didn't choose this opening because
it's good for white it's definitely not
good for white
but he's chosen it because it's
surprising he's trying to use that
psychological surprise value on
pragnanda giving him a pawn structure
here which
he's unlikely to have ever studied
before and yeah dude are hoping his
greater experience might pay off later
but it's a bit tense for now no direct
tactics just both sides controlling
squares trying to improve their pieces
and i guess if there is one thing prague
has struggled with in the tournament he
has been in some time trouble yeah he's
handled the time trouble really well
even when he's been low on the clock
he's played quite well in general maybe
the exception being that day against
magnus carlson where he kind of panicked
a couple of times low on the clock but
yeah that's the one thing he's had
throughout his entire career actually
even when i played him three four years
ago he was already getting very very low
on the clock uh very early so i think
it's uh something that i've heard him
talk about in interviews his coach
talked about in interviews they're
trying to work on that but so far it's
not really not really
come back to bite him maybe that's what
duda is hoping for maybe that's the only
kind of weakness that dude is spotted
when analyzing pregs games but is that
also the biggest sign of a player in top
form when they are able to handle
uh time trouble really well they just
the intuition is they're working exactly
it's all about intuition trusting it and
also calculating super fast and that's
one thing the youngsters are really good
at uh it's like a math equation if you
ask them what uh 12 times 12 is they'll
work it out instantly and uh yeah the
players is same with chess variations
they'll say okay bang bang bang bang
bang that's the answer and they'll make
a move
so that's why he can handle being low on
the clock but
it's just about whether he can kind of
keep the position stable
while he does while the clock does tick
down
all right it is game one here on day six
and we're following duda against prague
behind prague is magnus carlsen against
eric hansen game one
the bar is slightly to the middle in all
the games actually magnus looking
focused today we could definitely hear
from his interview yesterday that he
still was a little bit sick
uh and david you are a friend of his
have you heard from magnus do you know
how he is feeling um i haven't heard too
much from him lately i guess because he
has been kind of locking himself away
trying to recover and uh i've heard that
he's feeling a bit better than he was
especially three days ago when he threw
four days ago when he had that loss to
liam and he was really really struggling
visibly so he's feeling better but
yesterday
still not 100
uh against jordan so
yeah i mean it's a pretty we don't see
the world champion kind of
at his best trying to chase down prague
but still i mean he looks pretty focused
today yes let's hope he is better and we
also have to give
so much praise to jordan van furice
because he did play some fantastic chess
yesterday that was a very entertaining
match jordan is today playing mamadiaro
that should be super entertaining yeah i
have to say that you know absolutely i
mean it will be like fire on the board
and i can see from
the answers to our competition where
we're asking who are you rooting for and
why um well shakaria and jordan both
have a lot of fans
for their creativity and just for their
ability to generate magic on the board
you know it's kind of like a game of
passion when they play
very nice yeah do you tweet us using the
hashtag chess champs who are you rooting
for and of course why
and
i did see the bar in the first game
between geary and leia
that one was actually quite
significantly over to giri's side yeah
and giri he will want to win in the
rapid portion he's lost three blitz
tiebreaks already this tournament hasn't
won any blitz tie breaks so he knows the
pressures on him to win the first few
games and liam in top form so it's not
going to be easy for giri despite the
fact he's doing well right now in the
first game so if you are rooting for
geary send him some love using the
hashtag chesschamps we're following duda
against prague and i did hear a few
moves yeah there were a couple of moves
and we have to jump in because something
has changed it's wow especially with
this last move it's getting really sharp
and simon talk us through these last few
moves because was this one surprising to
you we mentioned white had not much to
do pushing forward with his pawn
allowing on passant capturing and now
jumping forward with the white knight
i think that seemed pretty logical um to
try and get the knight to a good square
but i'm more surprised by
prague's reaction because uh we
mentioned
one of the real strengths of black's
position uh was this pawn in the center
of the board which we can highlight
there that kind of cuts white's
positioning too and
prague with his next move this is what
shocked me has lost control of that pawn
and he's grabbed harry the h-porn and we
know that harry loves sacrificing
himself anyway he's kind of a bit of a
relevant pawn and uh i think now duda
can win a central pawn and central pawns
are better than wing porn so i i don't
quite understand
unless there's some tactical reason
why
black why prague has gone for this and i
think we're going to see that well
dave's just putting it on the board and
yeah why is why has he done that i mean
you've anchored you yeah do you know any
good reasoning behind it
could also be like nerves it could be
the fact that you know he's just
thinking about the situation because
it's often a sign when you're nervous
that you play a little bit too um in a
forcing way
you just it's just a little bit
irresistible because it makes no sense
what uh
what uh prague nanda has just played
because after all
he's just traded off white's worst minor
piece the dark light squared bishop and
he gave up black's really important pawn
in the center for just an isolated weak
pawn on the side of the board black's
queen now offside really needs to take a
time out to kind of step back centralize
herself so prague's firstly losing time
with his queen on the next turn but uh
yeah white now look at the two-point
pawns in any end game white's got great
chances because these two white pawns
have no rivals uh black meanwhile with a
set of doubled pawns not ideal if you
imagine the white knight remember queen
and knight are great attacking combo if
the white knight can pick itself up and
kind of plant itself on one of the weak
light squares around the black king it's
going to be game over black with only
the dark squared bishop has no influence
on the light squares so this one's i
feel in practical term terms turning in
white's favor but then again prague does
have a nice strong bishop uh if you can
line it up with the queen maybe he's
doing well and uh still not too many
weaknesses apart from these light
squares in sky's position such a
horrible positional decision though from
prague uh just just um you know you i
mean if someone had played that like 40
years ago let's say i mean maybe
nowadays in modern chess you can kind of
get away of it but 40 years ago you say
oh yeah he's only a 16 year old you know
he's only a youngster he'll learn how to
play positional chess when he gets a bit
older but um like i i really don't know
why he why he's done that because it was
such a nice pawn in the center of the
board i think his answer lies there he
actually thinks
that his control over the dark squares
is probably going to be worth
all those kind of all those exchanges it
seems strange though he might be doing
okay now but it was like you did have a
safe i would say position advantage so
why are you giving up all your
positional advantages because if that
diagonal doesn't work now he's just
going to be worse so it just seems seems
a bit odd but yeah i don't approve
either i think it's not even that this
position is bad because black has some
chances it's just the fact that his
position earlier was very very strong
and he had kind of long-term advantages
there so he gave up all those long-term
advantages just just to trade things off
and to simplify uh the position and now
it's the type of position i was about to
say white's king can even start getting
ready for an end game centralizing
itself there white's king is pretty safe
because black has no knights no light
squared uh pieces to attack it and there
we go prague having to waste time
retreating the queen back where she came
from
um so yeah it's still in the balance for
now i young players as well liking their
bishops so maybe prague still enjoys
this position um but yeah it's anything
goes now it's are we starting to see
some nerves do you think i think his
decision trading off those pieces
must have been influenced by nerves
maybe the clock situation as well he's
down five minutes on the clock and he
thought
it's human nature as well to think uh
okay trading things makes things more
simple but often by trading
your good pieces for your opponent's bad
pieces you actually uh allow the
momentum to change as well and here we
go dude is improving his night maybe
long term heading towards those squares
that i mentioned
uh if he can get there yeah so dude with
the white pieces he wants to win in this
game is he fighting for that win or or
does it look very drawish yeah duda i
mean even if the position
starts kind of fizzling out he'll look
for tricks he'll look for traps just
with his opening choice alone he showed
that he wants to win this game
desperately
uh yeah duda still doing okay in the
tournament but he really wants to win
this game yeah absolutely i mean duder
that is his kind of uh trademark
fighting spirit fighting play
and uh okay pragnanda is he is he
setting a trap
i mean the whole idea maybe it's just to
push the
two squares forward and that would be
quite nasty if duda were not paying
attention yeah for example if white just
gets kind of careless and pushes his own
pawn then suddenly this could be a real
problem for the white queen she doesn't
really have too many safe squares and if
she retreats then suddenly the black
queen is going to jump in with a nasty
check and this looks scary right javanka
this is the trap you mean yeah this does
look very very scary you never want to
allow an enemy queen in your side of the
board especially one entrenched on that
particular square yeah and even though
the king for now survives i mean
suddenly you cut off this diagonal you
cut off this diagonal and you could
definitely imagine this going very very
wrong for the white king so a bit of a
trap in the position and what we'll do
to do uh maybe he has to push a pawn
forward just to cover the light squares
maybe he has to use his knight i'm not
sure which way you should jump either
forward or backward uh just to cover
that key square that we mentioned the
black queen wants to use later on yeah
at least prague he's got concrete ideas
behind what he's doing he's not just
playing moose for the sake of them he
does have a plan black wants to push his
pawn forward
all right now simon you were talking
about these computers and how good these
youngsters are getting does that mean
that it's
inevitable that uh the new players
magnus and the players coming after him
will be the best in history would bobby
fisher for example have a chance today
against these players
i am i think someone like bobby i mean
it's a question that comes up quite a
lot how do the old world champions will
relate to the new new players new world
champions and i think
if you let the old world champions use
computers then they could hone in on
their uh natural talent and then you
know be as strong if not stronger than
the modern players but it really is
adapting and it really is the technology
is so important nowadays
for getting stronger at chess because
if you don't have a computer you're
going to be so
you know you're going to be such have
such a problem to play against these
guys who know everything so it's uh i
mean i don't know how a very interesting
question how would bobby fischer
compare to magnus carlsen i mean
say we picked up bobby fischer from 1972
and we put him in eric hanson's chair to
play magnus in a match today i mean
without looking at a computer or maybe
they wouldn't play computer chess let's
say they would have
played it over the board match but with
the same knowledge that bobby fisher in
1972
straight out in 1972. i think he'd get
crushed in the other thing
or in general i think bobby fischer
would struggle because i agree he also
played very sharp openings he plays them
he's probably going to get in trouble
in all the openings so uh yeah i think
it would be difficult incidentally one
of our participants has a real life
story just like that really yeah and he
told me during the chess talks okay
let's hear you want to hear do you want
a spoiler okay it was shakira mama
jaroff okay 2002
in the blood olympiad um he wasn't using
computers he was just using books and so
he prepared using a book from the 70s
and he played judith poger and guess
what you know judith holger has been
using computers she had been preparing
she knew the latest theory he got wiped
off the board he was chancellors yeah so
uh yeah anyway you'll find out more in
my chess talks which is coming with uh
with mommy that's coming out uh i think
that's going to be published on friday
if i'm not mistaken yeah yeah well yeah
i have to say because magnus faces
shakira tomorrow on the final day in the
tournament so we're going to talk more
about it but there's one player's
life story that you really need to
listen to it's actually
majaro yeah what a player what a person
we do have a move on this online game we
do have a move and it's one of the moves
that we did mention was probable from
white uh you had to guard your light
square somehow we showed that variation
with the black queen coming down to the
square that the pawn now sits on and by
occupying the light squares with pawns
duda has kind of stopped and prevented
any infiltration from the black queen
so in on one hand you weaken the dark
squares in the white camp but you do
cover all of the light squares so very
sensible from duda i'm expecting prague
to maybe adopt a similar strategy anyway
and start throwing pawns towards the
white queen
um it's not exactly clear where prague
should be aiming for uh he ideally wants
to improve his own queen but maybe the
first job is to kick away white's queen
from this dream central post and i just
saw the bar just jumped up for magnus
carlsen in game one
against eric hansen look at that
is he uh winning that game has something
happened it does look good um still a
lot of work to be done for magnus but
the trend is in his favor and it does
look like maybe eric's just made a
mistake so
um it's been very difficult for eric for
a while he actually played eric the same
opening where he lost a prague yesterday
magnus is copying prank strategy which
is really interesting uh magnus of
course studying all his opponents games
but
yeah eric
just yeah he's uh he's maybe a bit like
some of the other players because he
doesn't get the chance to study so much
uh because he's streaming so uh so often
he's struggling in the opening just like
bobby fischer would if you were living
in the present day interesting all right
well we're going to keep an eye on this
game as well but we are following duda
against pragnanda and dudas
coaches it or friend adam he's arrived
oslo as well and he's out in the lounge
with zlatan
thank you kai yes i'm standing here next
to adam and
it's interesting because yesterday you
guys were supposed to have a great
birthday celebration but
younger stuff was maybe not the happiest
after the game were you still able to
have a good time i think he was he had a
good time yesterday but you know when
you have a birthday during the
tournament
it's a bit tricky to celebrate so we
just you know
shake hands discuss what would happen
within the next year then came here so
thank you for this celebration because
that was a big surprise for janae but
then he had to concentrate on the game
and play
how are you viewing this game playing
out right now against pragnan london i
think that prague is
one of the most talented
from the newest generation because you
know yannick was the newest generation a
few years ago now he's 24 the prague is
coming and the other are coming so i
think i'm very happy that there is a
pressure
on him as he is pressuring the older
generation like
magnus and all those people so so the
game is quite interesting because
usually it's not the standard
game janak doesn't like to play you know
the theory he plays to challenge his
opponent
so i wish them great games and a lot of
satisfaction for the supporters of both
players and all the spectators
but it must be great satisfaction also
for you traveling with your neck and
also yonick's fans right now with being
a candidates player performing so well
in general
is it is it enjoyable to go on these
trips when the results are so good
actually i don't travel that much janek
is traveling with grand master camille
mitchell who is his coach
this time he came with robert kempinski
who is also a grand master several times
single civil war and european champion
but robert had to return back to poland
so i am replacing him so my contribution
to the preparation is not that big at
least i'm trying to keep the good mood
but but that is just i honest question
is that just as important to keep the
mood up as keeping the preparations up
for sure for sure for the player i think
we need to address everything not only
chess and we do it with your nx so we
also really
appreciate the all the supporters in
poland and all around the world because
we have plenty of supporters in almost
all of the countries
and yannick says that
the support is for him extra 100 points
of hello
so we really really appreciate it so
maybe you can give us a tip if you're
not traveling with him the next time
what do we do to yannick to make him
happy if he's having a bad day i think
he's always happy when he wins so then
you can do whatever you want with him
when he's not winning then you know the
mood is a bit different
i'm in touch with the team but usually
i'm not trying to interrupt them when
they are playing on the tournament so
even if i am at the tournament
i am not providing you know and then
guidances and whatever and just have a
chat
with camilla and with with yannick
because you know they are professionals
in that space i am professional in
another space and we
are trying to focus on the things we do
best
it's uh i find that most people
connected with chess players to say one
thing they're the happiest when they win
and everything else is secondary but
right now it's looking even in the
evaluations at least guys
absolutely
thank you sweater and adam i think uh
manager is maybe the right term to use
about
adam he's traveling with young christoph
and helping him out with many things and
we did have a few moves on the board the
queen's dancing around yeah the queens
have been embarking on a little dance
there and one interesting moment which
has passed actually but duda offered a
trade of queens and prague said no with
prague's last move the black queen
dodged a trade do you like that simon
keeping the queens on the board dude
they're just improving in the white rook
i was going to say earlier i think if if
black exchanges queens black's going to
be in a lot of trouble well not a lot of
trouble but that certainly helps white's
chances i mean black's one big aim here
is to use his queen and try to get the
queen infiltrate it into white's
position uh you can see where the white
king is maybe david can just highlight
some squares around there where the
queen could maybe try to get into um so
you see the black yeah those two squares
the black queen can somehow get into
those positions black is doing okay so
so that's obviously a queen exchange
helps white uh hence why um uh prague is
not doing that just moving the rook up
here no there's a sneaky sorry sorry
dennis
i got a bit excited there because i was
like why put the rook in the middle of
the board why not move it to the open
line that's what i always advocate and
then suddenly i realized hang on a
second he's got a sneaky idea
he actually by stepping forward with the
with the rook two squares he wants to
tuck the queen behind the rook threaten
the pawn and then
move on to attack the queen perhaps yeah
so for example if white just makes a
move um for example stepping back with
the queen maybe one idea would be to
step the queen back this is your idea
yeah yeah
that goes passive and if white goes
passive and defends this pawn then you
have ideas of maybe swinging across
along this line or even or even just
like trying to explode things open on
the left yeah or maybe pushing some
pawns on the left side of the board you
could make an argument for pushing
either of these pawns trying to break
through to the white king and uh the
white king may be the big target right
now black's king relatively safe no
pieces around it and after this uh
sneaky clever rook move with the idea of
maybe swinging across later to attack
white's queen white's queen has
preempted that by moving herself
and now if the black queen steps back
maybe
jan kristoff's idea is to bring his
knight forward so defending this pawn
but also trying to sneak forward to some
very nice light squares it's all about
black's dark square control on this
diagonal versus white's fight back in
the center and on the light squares and
the bar is uh sneaking over to prague's
side is it starting to get interesting
it's heating up nicely um still early
days uh prague there just attacking the
white queen
still a lot of action ahead i feel and
it could go either way we'll see the
evaluation by the back towards the
center
it's a very difficult position to handle
especially with not that much time on
the clock probably more difficult for
white here as well i mean uh black's
play is a bit more natural and if white
does the wrong move you're going to
allow that black queen to get into the
position so it's more tricky for white
um but i'd say positionally in the long
run better better for white
but you know can white exchange queens
that's the thing if it goes really wrong
for white you just get checkmated if it
goes really wrong for black you get up
you kind of find yourself in a worse end
game so it's still not the end of the
world maybe
hang on a second
do you think this potentially could be
an offer of a draw from duda you know
every time the position repeats itself
ivanka you think it will be a draw i i'm
just just putting it out there you know
maybe you know he's saying hey let's
repeat moves and uh see whether you're
happy with a draw
because it seems so happy about the
thought of a repertoire but i'm thinking
please don't draw no no
obviously obviously that's not my
favorite thing in the world but you know
i just do like getting under
just getting into their minds and trying
to predict whether it's a draw offer
because i mean sometimes these are the
thoughts that uh plague you during a
game is your opponent offering a draw
are they happy with that kind of thing
what's going to happen if they offer you
a draw
maybe it doesn't happen to david because
he plays
for a lot of players who are weaker than
him and he also has a very combative
style and attitude but for me sometimes
i'm thinking oh
i know it actually it actually plays
your emotions a bit
because like you know i don't know you
you could just want to draw
if you're playing a long tournament you
won't have a day off not david but okay
everyone else is normal not this hundred
moon grinder
exactly he's gotta make them really go
over a hundred moves but sometimes the
draw you're playing someone stronger and
like sometimes they like repeat the
position likes happening here i expect
this
position now it is yeah this could well
be a draw but it's like and then they
decide the last moment i don't want to
draw and you're like
another couple of hours here then so so
who do you think would want to draw more
here do dot or prague who is going to
repeat or who is going to avoid
repeating the position i don't think
dude will be repeating the position i
mean morally speaking he has the white
pieces more time on the clock got more
time on the clock and so therefore i
think he will be
happier
with playing on yeah i think prague
likes his position just judging from his
body language looking very focused
trying to get into the computer screen
but yeah it's just the clock time i
think that's worrying him
and you're right ivanka duda doesn't go
for the draw he brings rook back where
it came from but the rook was here just
a few times ago
no real progress surprising move i'm
glad he played on for the win uh but a
surprising move though did it worsen his
position a little bit i mean it's just
because the rook what was it three moves
ago stood on the same square he brought
it to the side and then just brought it
back so he's lost a bit a bit of time
there and
because white lost time black pushes
forward yeah i was going to say this
this looks like a good move doesn't it
because we mentioned the black queen not
wanting to exchange itself and we can
maybe just show on the analysis board
that uh you know let's say white moves
the rook upper square or something now
the black queen can go one square over
and it can't be exchanged because it's
blocked by the pawn and that prager's
just moved and the black queen is trying
to dive in i love it when you get two
pieces on the same diagonal it's like
double power you know it's really good
they're really powerful one supports the
other they want to dive into the
position and uh this is starting to
become some actual you know i mean white
threats big threats yeah definitely you
don't want to allow that queen into your
position that could be
terrifying yeah so really nice sneaky
idea of pushing pawns forward it looks
like you're
trying to control squares gain space but
as simon mentioned setting up a nice uh
idea attacking idea for prague trying to
sneak in using this diagonal and
therefore duda either on the next move
uh or right now even he's got to push
his pawn forward this bishop's diagonal
is too strong as we showed there
especially once the black queen occupies
it so either now or on the next few
times he has to push forward and maybe
allow some trades but
that at the best is going to lead to a
draw for white swapping things off gives
away any chances i think of white trying
to win the game okay he does play it
maybe out of necessity and now if we do
see a capture we don't i was about to
say if we see a capture white knight
springs to the center of the board
instead we see prague keep the tension
swinging his queen across now on this
diagonal white can never touch this pawn
if you play pawn takes pawn immediately
checkmate on the board so this is the
danger facing duda if he's careless he
might end up getting uh end up being
checkmated any time now and they're both
under two minutes now uh all of a sudden
i didn't realize how low on time they
had got so it's one of those ones where
it will spring to life very shortly and
that's where you need a bit of time i
think it's going to be a very very
exciting uh finish here an excitement
for magnus carlsen he has now won game
one against eric hanson great start
for magnus he needs it he needs to win
today's match he is uh trying to
catch up with pragmata he's in the lead
in the tournament
do you think he can win this game
anything's still possible then
anything's still possible but i like
what he's doing pregnant and he's
definitely playing for the win he kind
of teased dudo with that repetition duda
said no but dudes had to worsen his
position uh just to avoid that draw and
uh i think dude is just stuck waiting
that white rook move
what's it really doing it's not clear i
think dude is just waiting for the
tension to be broken
it's going to be hard to win this game
for pragnando to actually push forward
and make progress and break through to
that white king but he's trying and
unless the clock stops him at one minute
he will keep trying to attack and he
pushes forward his pawns um
will the pawn go one square forward i'm
thinking of freddie
marching at one square just to
destabilize
the pawn structure that white has or
will pragnanda just simply wait somehow
i suspect waiting is probably a good
idea i think probably waiting yeah i
mean
the only danger i can see oh he's played
it okay right so that does surprise me
maybe it's okay but i wouldn't really
want to get black pawn
fixed in the middle so for example
again maybe we can show if if white
takes that pawn now um and i don't know
how this is exactly going to turn out
but let's just say black now takes the
pawn in the middle he's got to take it
with his pawn
and you can see that that black pawn it
could be very strong this could well
occur but it it blocks up the queen so
the queen can now no longer have these
ideas attacking the white king so
in some ways i'd say the white and we're
having this on the board the white king
is now a bit safer than it was
because you've got rid of that diagonal
by blocking it with one of your own
pawns so
i'm a little bit surprised he rushed
that one maybe he could have been a
little bit slower and this is something
you know you could say is well i don't
know if it is a fault but you know
you're 16 years old maybe it's very
common to try and rush ideas and one
thing at this age you need to do
is slow down and just wait until you
make a push like this is it's a common
error at 16. on the plus side though yes
this pawn is kind of a double agent here
you actually want to remove it from the
board as black but you are tying down
white's rook for eternity if white's
rook ever moves you immediately push
forward and break open your own diagonal
again
and black will pretty much win if that
diagonal becomes open so yeah i agree
with you simon positionally
strategically it looks wrong just feels
wrong somehow to put this pawn on a dart
square block up your own pieces block up
this diagonal that looks so good but at
least you've tied down white's rook and
duda can't ever touch his rook right now
so he has to move his knight instead
there is a threat of the knight coming
to the center and hitting the queen
hitting the rook
so a big big threat that prague has to
deal with you don't really want to trade
queens here either if you trade queens
off even if you grab a pawn temporarily
then after the white knight jumps
forward this is a fork a double attack
and suddenly yes black can defend the
bishop but i think we would just see a
draw at maximum for black after the
pieces start to disappear 20 seconds i
was gonna say that though i just
realized he's got down he's you know
he's moving very slowly with his time
isn't he okay good move though he
removes his rook away so now the knight
jumping into the center is not so
dangerous black can just move his queen
but uh where to go that's the problem at
least now white's piece is all on light
squares uh they're starting to combine
coordinate in the center of the board
30 seconds for prague one minute for
duda
no no no no not a lot of time also you
know that's not the only night move that
can that attacks the queen as well so
definitely a lot of choice for duda but
he's also now under a minute
and uh when the
well you know what happens when the
clock gets under a minute well you start
to sweat a little bit
and just uh start to feel the heat yeah
i'm getting energy we saw just a moment
ago by shaking his leg really fast i've
noticed when i was young i used to do
that as well just rock up and back and
forth get the energy get the blood
pumping but it's so annoying when people
do that
how do i get them or i think you did it
too simon
i i would never dream of doing such a
thing
i mean you do it unintentionally but uh
it's really annoying when your
opponent's shaking the table with their
leg and you're like
stay still i mean while we did see a
quick trade there the knight and bishop
have left the board and dude i'm making
a face he's not so happy with this last
move the white queen is pinning a pawn
look at the g-file the black pawn there
on the right side cannot move the black
queen would fall
uh i'm expecting now prague to start
trying to activate the black queen if he
can pick up the black queen put it
somewhere near the white king
chances for an attack still 20 seconds
though he needs to move
not easy not easy because uh well
white's queen is also incredibly active
and will start attacking pieces of her
own so okay
brag this is a this is maybe a good
safety
choice i thought this is probably one
way that the game could go towards a
draw um now if the queen's come off i i
think it's very likely everything gets
swapped off we could show and just
wait one second
we'll have a kind of yeah
for the win prague under 10 seconds
there and he moved he's playing for the
win not trading queens not heading
towards that potential draw actually
that end game would have still been
tricky but now that queen lining herself
up with the white king interesting
decision by prague we have a draw
between jordan pham for east
we saw both of them leaving the oslo
esports arena
two games still going on here this one
and the bar is swinging over to do the
side
dude there is one pawn up after all yes
it's ugly doubled pawns for white on the
f-file but a pawn is a pawn and now
prague going back with this rook where
it came from losing time mike's pawns
might start advancing now yeah no i i
didn't really approve of this last move
i mean i think it's very instinctive
time trouble move but it does waste time
i think he needed to get on the counter
offensive with his pieces and uh well
prague is now doing this he's now
activating the queen this is good you
need to keep your pieces you need to
keep them alive yeah and black's queen
is attacking one of white's pawns the
white pawn on the f2 square the black
queen is attacking right now
if that pawn drops white is in big
trouble so dude has to take a timeout
and defend that pawn maybe using the
white queen the white rook if it moves
you have to worry about
the pawn that is currently blockading
moving down and giving a check
computer likes white
how is dude are going to defend okay he
brings his rook across really brave move
there and how does prague keep the
momentum going he just needs to escape
this game with a draw i think yes he
played for the win earlier he still
wants to win but the winning chances
have gone for black you need to be super
careful now and oh okay this last move
lining the queen up with the white king
but
that's been shut down white defending
everything i mean maybe you can roll the
dice and push push the blackboard center
if i was black here short time i i just
start rolling the dice and check the
king try to get my queen around the back
because white has a very simple plan now
white can move the point he's done it so
two seconds for probably two seconds but
i think he had to try this idea now he's
gotta if he can get the black queen into
the position then he's gonna be doing
very well here but how do you get the
black queen into the position okay oh
he's done it lovely maneuver that one is
lovely it looks lovely
but the pawn comes yeah yeah actually
maybe and it does two squares from
queening how does he get the black queen
in prague shaking his head i think he
missed this one he's panicking under
five seconds again
time is so important
he has the move
okay he moves his queen okay he has a
deadly threat on the board the queen is
going to swoop down
at your van canal
he has done
okay but the queen and rook said they're
deadly attackers so i mean it's looking
really really really bad for pragnanda
but
never say never until
they shake hands what they don't shake
hands these days but until the game is
over
i'm gonna say never ivanka unfortunately
i think this game is gone for prague
yeah it's two pawns and uh the white
king can never be attacked just by the
queen really now so you need a bit of a
bit of a miracle don't you i'm afraid
we've seen miracles happen like i'm
going to be there a town or optimist
here i woke up in a good mood
i'm santa
yes
yes i do yes sent nicholas here you go
i'm more of a scrooge type
[Applause]
no i mean i think he needs he does need
a miracle here unfortunately i mean his
brave play from both players i mean i
think duder's decision
fortunately favors the brave was was you
know when he turned down the draw it was
really really uh you know big decision
and it seems to be paying off now and
it's just doing a quick count is all we
need to do white has these two extra
pawns uh on the f-file white has the
attacking pieces as well compare the
rooks white's rook's super active black
stroke permanently passive the black
queen is just fighting a battle on her
own but uh this is the type of position
where duda excels as well he's so good
at these queen type of end games where
you kind of have to balance off
attacking and defending the black king
is a target white's king a target too
but white's king can even start running
up the board at some point
17 seconds for duda clock is ticking
down yeah he has to make a move he has
to keep control of this position okay
give a check with the queen maybe
five seconds or the clock yeah the clock
might play a big factor though maybe
we've written off prague too soon this
is a check he's regained one of his
pawns the white king now he's got to
match up the board surely okay he might
treat maybe come to the king's side this
is like you know
if the white king actually gets on the
other side of that pawn which is moving
towards it's going to have quite good
defense
because your very advanced pawn also
stops things as david can quickly point
out there and the pawn white's pawn
right up the top of the board does a
useful role of guarding the g8 square
the one diagonally to the right there so
you can't get checked so this actually
seems like quite a safe place
for the white king and uh while whilst
you're doing this the winning idea would
be able to get the white rook
you know to one of those squares david
highlighted maybe he can try that now
has he gone for it no okay
oh he's going for a check mating
rob dude yeah really nice move there
centralizing the white queen and if the
black rook had taken this pawn as simon
says this would actually end in
checkmate the black king caught on its
back rank so big big threat in the
current position if we catch up black's
going to try and give some checks but
white actually wants to bring his queen
to the top of the board with a check
kicking away this black rook if for
example a pawn move check you give up
one queen but you replace it with
another you win a rook in the process so
big big threat in the position and
prague trying to defend with his queen
uh this is a really defensive setup now
let's go back to the players can do to
break this down prague just curling up
into a ball
look at the king and rook now tucking
his king away to safety it's not going
to be easy though it's very one-sided it
is very one-sided but on the other hand
prague's one hope is that the white king
is pretty exposed and that means that
duda can't play the active moves that he
really wants to do right now
yeah but he has a winning plan i feel
and prague's shaking his head he knows
the white king is going to do what you
said simon run away to safety there we
go it starts its journey to hide behind
one of its own pawns
and the simple plan for white he's going
to lift his rook up one square conquer
the eighth rank
that white pawn is going to promote to a
new queen
i imagine
i think at some point that's going to
happen but i mean prague is doing a
great job and he's got to get his queen
he has got it behind that pawn now so if
the white rook goes up he can take it
the moves are coming quick and fast
queen exchange that's a lovely idea
really lovely square for the queen if
the queens come off white is winning and
now there's a threat a queen takes black
rook as well uh which will be
devastating so you just got to check and
hope but king f3 now yeah
run towards
run towards the airport
and
if he escapes the checks which he should
be able to do it's going to be game over
um because the big threat in the
position is the white queen taking the
black rook
because the only thing stopping white's
far advanced pawn is that rook let's
quickly show this uh if black had taken
a timeout then the winning move the
winning ideas queen takes rooker simon
says uh just removing the defender and
making a new queen here queen and rook
would beat a lone queen so the big
question is in this position how do you
escape the checks how do you gain time
to go and take this rook uh dude he's
trying to zigzag with his king he's kind
of done a dance with his king now
and uh
craig he'll still keep checking he's
gonna give a check with his queen in the
middle of the board surely there's
nothing else to do you don't even need
to think give this check
okay prague to 30 seconds he needs to
hope that the checks don't run out duda
if he can run to safety for example
maybe moving his king up the board and
uh maybe blocking with his queen at some
point maybe he's going to win this game
but still prague fighting really hard
and he has gone for the check he's got
to go for the check there's no other no
other choice okay the king's come back
so so how yeah how is he going to win
can he block with a queen now does that
help because you keep doesn't work
because this way you're still
threatening to take the black rook into
position um very clever way so this this
yeah this is good and now you can just
move the pawn i guess move the white
king back one square high and super safe
and a beautiful idea right the queen is
simply going to take the rook
and uh once the king captures the queen
it's going to be a rook check and the
queenie square is supported
there's no more defensive resources now
for uh
tough start for prague this one yeah i
mean uh it was very interesting game um
but he he maybe got a little bit
impatient i feel that um just at one
point when he started pushing his pawns
uh and his time management has been
under five seconds he's got to move
okay and now
queen takes rook or this rook move both
are winning black's rook can no longer
guard the eighth rank white is about to
make a new queen what's about to win a
rook and duda knows it he knows that
this is the point where prague is just
going to lose
yep and okay one last check from prague
but the offer of a queen trade will end
the game if queens come off white is
simply winning and
heartbreak for prague yeah look at that
he is about to lose game one here
pragmata and there it is he resigns it's
over young christophe duda wins game one
all right remember pragnanda in the lead
in the tournament magnus carlsen he won
his first game and if magnus wins
today's match and prague loses